- Du willst dir das Zimmer anschauen?
- Ja. Ich suche eine neue WG.
- Wir haben telefoniert.
Ich bin Lisa Brunner.
- Cool.
- So, äh, das ist die Wohnung.
- Hi, Lisa.
- Das ist …
- Marvin, hi.
- Marvin möchte dein Zimmer sehen.
- Ah, hi!
Ich bin Nawin. Freut mich.
- Hi.
- Schon okay …
- Wo ist Emma?
- Draußen mit Nina.
- Okay.
- Okay, dann fangen wir an!
- Äh, das ist das Wohnzimmer.
- Die Fenster sind groß und
das Zimmer ist hell.
- Cool.
Wie viele Zimmer hat die Wohnung?
- Es gibt fünf Zimmer, eine Küche
und ein Bad.
Ja, dann komm mal mit.
- Los, los, los, los, komm!
- Das Zimmer ist frei für dich.
- Ganz schön groß.
Wie viele Quadratmeter
hat das Zimmer denn?
- Ich glaube, es hat
zehn Quadratmeter, oder?
- Äh, das Zimmer
hat elf Quadratmeter.
- Ah.
- Ja, und es ist sehr ruhig.
Keine Autos.
- So, das ist die Küche.
Die Küche ist sehr gemütlich. Hier
sitzen wir oft.
- Wie teuer ist das Zimmer?
- Die Miete kostet mit Nebenkosten
400 Euro im Monat.
- Okay.
Ich nehme das Zimmer!
- Super … Äh ...
Es kommen noch andere Interessenten.
Aber wir rufen dich an.
- Ja, cool. Na dann! Tschüss!